Cassandra is with us in Oregon hi
Cassandra welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thank you so much I'm so
excited to talk with you you too how can
I help
okay so last September I bought
round-trip ticket to Europe for a solo
trip that I want to take and I bought it
on a credit card because Dave I have
been writing the stupid train for most
of my life however the very next day I
discovered your your show and I started
myself on the baby steps immediately I
gave myself plastic surgery I'm like
committed to not going into debt anymore
however I still have these tickets that
are non-refundable and non-transferable
so do I use so I'm able to cash flow if
I go but that will also include my baby
step one emergency fund okay so let's
stop a second okay you have airline
tickets that are non-transferable
non-refundable yes because I highly
unusual must have been some kind of deal
would you pay for them 500 okay and so
the question is in order to protect a
$500 investment that I made unwisely
prior to getting off the stupid train
so we're not shaming you okay I'm just
making sure I'm recounting what you said
okay you've made this decision before
not after you started thinking about our
stuff and about being responsible with
money I got that so so you're gonna pass
on that that's in the past okay but in
order to protect a $500 investment I
would end up using my very last dime out
of my baby starter emergency fund and
come home completely broke what do you
make a year I'm so I just
um graduated from school and got my
first life goes into freelancing writing
and the last four months I've made
eleven thousand in the next four months
I'm planning on making double that okay
and how much debt do you have I have
just over seventy thousand okay well
you're doing really well with your
writing congratulations thank you you're
monetizing that at a really good rate
okay and where are these tickets to
where's this trip um so it is flying
into Paris and flying out of Amsterdam
planning to be there how long two weeks
how old are you 28 all right so let's
kind of run this out you don't take the
trip basically we put five $100 bills in
the middle floor and we set them on fire
effectively correct mm-hmm
and you're making five to ten thousand
dollars a month and you clean up your
$70,000 and you have a fully funded
emergency fund and you save up five
thousand dollars for a proper European
trip and and at that point you are 30
years old right I uh the other
possibility is you go now and you come
home 1,000% broke which pretty much says
you're inviting trouble while you're in
Europe or at least by the time you get
home because one thing is for sure when
you take yourself down to absolute zero
money it's like you're asking for it you
know I'm saying it's like you're saying
please God make my life into a country
song you know I mean everything that can
go wrong will right right and so I
you're you're 28 my son is 28 where he
to ask me this exact same question I
would say
the emotional pain that you're gonna
feel when you burn these airline tickets
is gonna drive you through the debt out
the other side into an emergency fund
into a proper trip to Europe and you
will never never forget the day that you
decided I'm not living like this anymore
yeah you're totally right yeah I love
that yeah so I like Paris and Amsterdam
they're both fun I was in Paris last
year and I mean I'm 60 I never saw the
place until I was 50 so you're gonna get
there 20 years sooner than me 30 years
20 you're sending me so not that that
matters that's not necessarily the bar
I'm just saying you'll survive and and
the difference is this okay when you get
where you're not broke anymore you
travel different traveling on the cheap
is like less than fun traveling in the
lap of luxury is called yeah baby
you know and that's living like no one
else so later I can travel like no one
else so yeah so I'm gonna brag okay not
to brag on me but to show you what I'm
talking about when we went to Paris we
stayed in the four seasons and eight and
three of the finest restaurants in the
entire freaking world and every one of
those meals cost more than almost you
know my first car right I mean it's
ridiculous it's a small percentage of my
world because I did the stuff early like
getting out of debt building the
emergency fund having the investments
tour now I can do stuff like that on the
nice not on the cheap and really enjoy
it versus like you know scraping around
in the gutters trying to find a nickel
while I'm in Paris to get through the
subway or something right and so I just
I want you to have this experience but I
want you to have a better version of
this experience with a better version of
you yeah but okay
yeah that sounds great thank you so much
Steve thank you I appreciate you calling
I'm honored to get to talk you through
that talk with you through that and then
of course you get to decide what to do
sometimes I have done things that are
dumb or I've coached people that have
done things that are dumb
and the algae that I get from the dumb
thing propels me through the change the
transformation into the wisdom it's like
every time I look at that stupid car I
hate that car because it was a dumb
decision and then I finally get rid of
it I won't never borrow money on a car
again you know it's that kind of thing
it's like the dumb thing solidifies the
never again thing that's really good for
us as a part of our transformational
experience good stuff Cassandra honored
to have you in our audience your rock
star kiddo
you're gonna do great